all right that was team durant now it's
time to meet their competition and to
help me out this time i'm bringing a
little magic from los angeles it's the
magic man himself magic take it away
this team has it all
they got champions
mvp
youth inexperience
bronze and brings they can dominate the
paint and they can shoot that thing from
deep
i put these guys up against anyone
this is team
lebron
appearing in his first all-star game as
a head coach from the defending western
conference champion phoenix suns monty
williams
[Applause]
and now let's meet our reserves
selected but not able to attend
three-time all-star from the utah jazz
donovan mitchell
injured and unable to play for team
lebron is a 10-time all-star from the
philadelphia 76ers james harden
[Applause]
he's making his all-star game debut
one of the most exciting players in the
league from your teeth land cavaliers
give it up
[Music]
[Applause]
he's also making his all-star game debut
he's the man in the middle for your
creatures
jared allen
an nba champion and the fierce floor
general making his all-star debut from
the toronto raptors
[Applause]
[Music]
he's one of the best point guards in the
game making his third all-star
appearance from the dallas mavericks
luca
duncan
[Applause]
a six-time all-star who gets buckets for
the eastern conference leading miami
heat jimmy
butler
[Applause]
the first player in nba history to rack
up 20 000 points and 10 000 assists
making his 12th all-star game appearance
from the phoenix suns the point guy
chris paul
and now let's meet the starters for team
lebron
he's the big man from the denver nuggets
the reigning nba most valuable player
appearing in the sport all-star game the
joker nicola yokic
[Applause]
one of the game's most versatile scores
making his fifth all-star game
appearance from the chicago bulls demar
derozan
[Applause]
he's the greatest three-point shooter in
nba history he's a two-time league mvp
a three-time nba champion and an
eight-time all-star from the golden
state warriors
stephen curry
[Applause]
he's been named defensive player of the
year and earned most valuable player
honors twice
the mvp of the 2021 nba finals from the
defending champion milwaukee bucks
giannis
[Applause]
a four-time champion
a four-time most valuable player
a four-time nba finals mvp
the leading scorer in all-star history
making his 18 for all-star on this stage
he's just the key from that group from
the lakers
[Applause]
let's give it up one more time for team
lebron
team lebron will be playing hard for the
kent state our promise scholars program
there it is everyone the match is set up
team lebron versus team durant it's nba
all-star 2022. cleveland stand up and
make some noise
thank you for joining the party
everybody enjoy the game once again is d
nice let it breathe people
fans let's hear it one more time for
machine gun kelly d nice dirk nowitzki
magic johnson and your 2022 nba
all-stars
[Music]
[Applause]